LAURA: Hi, everyone and welcome.
And thank you so much
for joining us today.
My name is Laura.
I work on accessibility
here at Google.
It's great to be here today.
And accessibility is something
that's really, really critical
and core to our
mission here at Google.
To organize the
world's information,
make it universally
accessible and useful.
And 15% of the global population
has some form of disability.
And we need to be thinking
about how people are actually
interacting with our interfaces
and with our devices.
Kind of stripping away
those assumptions of how
we might think that
they're interacting
and really building
inclusive products.
When we are thinking about
the principles of accessible
design, it's often helpful to
kind of break down the groups
into personas of users and think
about the different interaction
models that people may be using.
So we can break down into
a few different groups.
For example, maybe thinking
about blind or low vision
users, deaf or hard of
hearing users, people
with motor dexterity
challenges, and people
who are considered
neurologically diverse,
or who have a range of
intellectual disabilities.
But there's a huge
population of people
that absolutely needs to be
factored into this discussion.
And that's the aging
population, which
has been growing and growing
since life expectancies have
thankfully been
increasing over the years.
And the World
Health Organization
estimates that by 2050
over 2 billion people
will be over the age of 60.
It's a huge population.
And as we all age we may
experience disabilities
in different ways.
We may experience just
slight deterioration
of certain senses, of vision,
of hearing, of dexterity,
for example.
Many other sorts of things.
So as technologists it's
really, really important
for us to factor in the needs
of this very important and very
large population.
So we're super
excited about today.
Tim?
TIM: Jeff Johnson is a
professor of computer science
at the University
of San Francisco.
There he teaches courses
that introduce students
to computer science
and also special topics
in human-computer interaction.
Beyond academia, Jeff has
worked as a UI designer
and implementer, an engineering
manager, a usability tester,
and a researcher at companies
like Cromemco, Xerox,
US West, Hewlett-Packard
Labs, and Sun Microsystems.
Building on a PhD
in psychology, Jeff
has spent decades contributing
to our understanding
of human-computer interaction.
He's addressed both
technical and social issues
including working as chair
of Computer Professionals
for Social Responsibility in
the late '80s and early '90s.
In 2016, Professor
Johnson was recognized
with a Lifetime Achievement
in Practice Award
from SIGCHI, the ACM
special interest group
on computer-human interaction.
At the award ceremony, Stanford
professor Terry Winograd
cited the influence of
Professor Johnson's books
on interface design.
Many of these books
stem from the idea
that you learn more
from things that don't
work than from things that do.
Today, Professor Johnson
will be sharing lessons
that he's learned from
things that don't work.
Because our bodies
change with age.
In designing user interfaces
for an aging population,
Jeff and his
collaborator Kate Finn
have built a
comprehensive resource
for technology
developers seeking
to produce products that can
be easily and successfully used
by older adults.
Please join me now in welcoming
Jeff and Kate to Google Today.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF JOHNSON: Thank you.
Is my microphone loud enough?
It is?
OK, good.
I want to thank Tim
and Laura for giving
the first half of my talk.
So this talk is
going to be based
on a book that Kate Finn,
who's sitting back there,
and I wrote.
The book is over there.
And apparently Tim is going
to be giving away copies of it
later.
And then there's
some other books
I wrote sitting there
for you to look at.
OK, so the population of the
world is aging on the average.
People live longer.
Birth rates are low.
And so humanity on the
average is growing older.
So let's look at some
numbers so that we
can see how much it's changing.
These are the top 10 countries
in the world that have
populations of people over 50.
And by the way, in
our book we use 50
as the line for
indicating older adults.
The reason that we
picked that number
is that most of the research
that we read in preparation
of the book uses that number.
So that age is an arbitrary age.
Some researchers talk about 60.
Some use 65.
But the bulk of them use 50.
And so we decided
to use that number.
OK, so if we look at
these top 10 countries,
China has nearly 400 million
people over the age of 50.
India has about 230 million.
The US is third.
Japan is fourth
and coming up fast.
It's got the most rapidly
growing percentage
of people over 50.
We can also look at the
information this way.
If you look at--
in 2015, basically
almost 20% of people
in the less developed areas
of the world were over 50.
Now, in the less
developed world, or what
we call the developing
world, population rates--
population growth
rates tend to be--
birthrates tend to be higher.
And therefore, there's a larger
percentage of younger adults.
And so the average
age of the population
tends to be lower than
in the developed world.
So in the developed
world, we can
see that in 2015
there was nearly 40%
of the population over 50.
And then as you can
see, the numbers
are expected to grow over
the next several decades.
Yet another way to look
at what's going on is--
people say, well, old
people don't use technology.
They don't go online.
But that's not really true,
as we can see from this chart.
This is broken
out by age groups.
And so as you can see, the
18- to 29-year-olds have
pretty much been online and
are still that way nearly 100%.
The next age group
is slightly less.
And then when we get
to 50-year-olds to 64,
it's slightly less.
But it's still growing.
And then the fastest growing
demographic on online
is people over 65.
Now, this is a little bit--
this graph is a little bit
problematic.
Because although
it sort of seems
to show these growth rates,
it's problematic because people
who are in one age group
age into another age group.
And therefore, of
course, this lower line
is going to go up as
the people who were
on this line become over 65.
So this chart has been
shown by Pew Internet
to show that people are
increasingly going online.
But I have some questions
about this chart.
So I prefer to look at it more
like this, where we take people
by birth generation,
which you don't move out
of your birth generation.
You stay in it.
So we have millennials, age--
people who were,
in 2016, 18 to 34.
Then we have Gen-X,
younger boomers, et cetera.
And we can look at the
percentages of them
that have adopted
technology, what
we call digital technology.
Now, when we say technology
in this talk or when I say it,
I essentially mean
digital technology.
Because of course, a horse
and a buggy is technology.
It's just older technology.
So the question is
where are people--
what kind of technology
are people using?
So for the purpose
of the talk, I'm
referring to digital technology.
We can also break
it up by device.
So we can see that
for tablets, there's
not a lot of
variability in who's
using tablets by age group.
There's some, but
not a whole lot.
There's not that much with
cell phones of all types.
Nearly 100% of people 18 to 29--
or actually, it is--
Pew puts it at 100% are using--
and again, we're talking
about the developed world--
are using digital
technology or cell phones.
And it doesn't vary
that much by age.
The oldest age group,
65 and over, is at 80%.
But when we look at
smartphones, there
is more of an age disparity.
But again, those bars
are all going up.
And especially the
smartphone for a 65-plus.
That's going up.
Two years ago it was at 30%.
Now it's at 42.
OK, so it's going up.
Laptops, and desktops,
and tablets, actually,
have been seen to slip
in the general population
over the last couple of years,
according to Pew Research.
They've started to
drop a little bit.
Now, the interesting thing about
the older than 50 population
is that technology,
digital technology,
can actually help
them quite a bit.
And here are some
quotes that were gleaned
from online sources of people
writing comments in response
to articles about
technology and older adults.
And so here's an
example of a quote.
"A Mac laptop opened
the world to me,
right here from
my kitchen table."
And it helped me because
of my physical disability.
My mobility is limited.
So this one, for the
benefit of people
who may not be able to
see this very well says,
"I can keep in touch with
people all over the world."
This one, "I feel so connected
in so much of the world.
Art, music, nature,
comedy, humanity."
And this one says, "Technology
has helped me move 19 times
in the past nine years,
taking everything with me."
"I can't imagine going back
to life without a computer."
So these are the kinds
of things that technology
can do for people whose mobility
is a little bit limited,
or who are socially isolated.
On the other hand, if we don't
design the technology well,
then we'll also get comments
like these, which are also
gleaned from online sources.
"How can I make the font bigger?
I can't see it!"
I wish they'd stop changing
things for no good reason.
All the technology is
just so confusing to me.
"Who thought thin grey
letters was a good idea?"
I hear that one a lot.
"So much to remember!"
"What happened to the menus?"
"I don't know
where to get help."
"Is this the
website, or an app?"
Actually, that's-- I don't
think that's so age dependent.
A lot of my students at USF
don't know the difference
between a website and an app.
"Where did my cursor go?"
Those kind of things.
So poorly designed
technology can
lead to these kinds of problems
especially for older adults.
Now, these problems are not
restricted to older adults.
But they impact older adults.
They tend to impact
older adults more
than the general population.
So illegible text,
bad passwords,
hard to remember
passwords, CAPTCHAs,
small targets, and the
difficulty of getting
tech support.
Those are all problems that
lots of people encounter.
But older adults
encounter them more often.
So let me just show you
an example of someone who
is in a usability test
that Kate and I conducted
a few years ago.
We were looking at older adults
using travel websites that
were aimed at older adults.
So you may not know, but
there's a whole industry--
there's a whole segment
of the travel industry
that's aimed at people who
are essentially retired.
Because they have
money and time.
So there are various companies.
And so we tried a bunch of those
websites with older adults.
Some of whom are
frequent travelers.
So these are not people
who are homebound people.
And so you get quotes--
you get situations
like this in the test.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So at this point,
if you were really
looking for a trip, what would
you do next if we weren't here.
What do you think?
- I would screw this.
[LAUGHTER]
- I would say, if
I can't get to what
I want in reasonable
tries, then this is not--
I don't want to go
to this company.
[END PLAYBACK]
JEFF JOHNSON: So they
just lost a customer.
So there's a
researcher in Britain
named Alan F. Newell, who is
different from the Alan Newell
that many of us know
in the United States.
But this is Alan
F. Newell who has
been researching designing for
older adults for many years.
And his famous-- one
of his famous quotes
is, "Design for older
adults, and you design
for almost everyone else."
There are many populations that
have similar usability issues
to older adults.
People with low vision, physical
impairments, low literacy,
little or obsolete technical
experience, second language
learners, and
cognitive impairments.
As we get older, people
often get these kind
of disabilities occurring.
And it varies
tremendously, as you know.
There are some
people who at age 95
are running marathons
and writing books.
And there are other
people who at age 60
are not capable of
those kinds of things.
And the other point
you can make is
that everyone is impaired
at least some of the time.
Even young people can have
trouble in some situations.
We often use the word
situationally disabled.
So you could have somebody who
was trying to use their cell
phone on a bus.
And the bus happens
to be driving down--
I don't know if you've been
to San Francisco recently,
but many streets
in San Francisco
are currently being torn
up as PG&E tries to update
50-year-old gas lines.
And so all these
streets are torn up.
And so the buses, and taxis,
and Uber cars, and everything
are bouncing along like this.
And people are trying
to use their cell phones
and having trouble texting.
And then, of course, you
have very common situations
like this one, like someone
trying to use a cell
phone while riding a horse.
But the point is that
the world shakes.
And therefore you
suddenly have tremors.
You have hand tremors.
So it's not just for old people
that we're designing this,
that we're trying to make
the technology accessible.
In fact, we can
look at it as trying
to build the digital
equivalent of curb cuts.
Because if you're
familiar with curb cuts,
they were mandated by
city ordinances that--
and maybe state ordinances--
that try to make sure that
everyone--
that people in wheelchairs
could use sidewalks.
But the percentage of people who
use wheelchairs over curb cuts
is actually very low compared
to people on skateboards, people
pulling roller bags, people
pushing shopping carts, people
pushing all sorts
of wheeled devices.
So curb cuts actually
help a large segment
of the population,
even though they
were put in place specifically
for people in wheelchairs.
That's what we're looking for.
Another example of
that kind of technology
is OXO kitchen appliances.
How many of you are familiar
with OXO kitchen appliances?
Anyone?
So the story is that this guy
who was kind of an inventor
noticed that his wife, who
had arthritis in her hands,
was having difficulty slicing--
peeling the potatoes.
And rather than helping
her peel the potatoes,
he invented a special
potato peeler for her.
Which his friends
started saying,
hey, that's really cool.
I want one.
And so he launched this
company and started
making these things.
And now they're famous for
making ergonomically designed
kitchen appliances.
So that's what we're looking
for in the digital world.
Things that can help
make digital technology
more accessible to older
adults and everyone else
at the same time.
Well, we've been
doing user interface
design for a long time.
There's a big user interface
design group here at Google.
They went to some of
the same universities
and took some of the
same courses that I did.
We should all know how
to do this by now, right?
The problem is that we don't.
And some of the reasons are
given here in this list.
We tend to design for
people like ourselves.
Technology producers
tend to be somewhat young
and have little experience
with older adults.
And if you just
provide them with data,
that's not good enough.
It doesn't make enough
of an impression.
Older adults are
often not included
in usability tests
or user research
for logistical reasons.
And some people just don't
think aging is a sexy topic.
So it often gets ignored.
There's also an
argument out there
that Kate and I have heard,
and you probably heard, too,
which is that, well, you
know, old people today
who don't know how
to use technology,
they're going to die.
And so let's not
worry about that.
Because everyone who's
grown up with technology
is going to grow up.
And they're going to
know how to use it.
And therefore, we don't
need to design especially
for those old people.
And so the terminology
that's been used is--
we refer to digital natives
versus digital immigrants.
So technically, I'm
a digital immigrant.
Because when I was
born, digital technology
didn't really much exist.
Or at least it wasn't
used by the public.
And so I didn't grow up with
it until I was in college.
And especially true
for my parents.
My parents were not--
did not grow up with it.
So we're digital immigrants.
And then the people who
grew up with the technology
all their lives, essentially,
are called the digital natives.
And so the idea of
this argument is,
just wait until the
digital natives take over,
and everything will be fine.
We won't have to
design especially
for those older adults.
That argument
doesn't hold water.
And I'll show you why.
We're familiar mostly
with these generations.
So there's the GI Generation,
Silent Generation,
Baby Boomers, et cetera.
And the blue bars show the
ages in which they were born.
So those generations are
defined by the range of years
in which they were born.
And so we can see
when the GI Generation
was born on this chart.
We can see when the
Silent Generation, which
is my parents, were born.
Baby Boomers, which is
the generation I'm in.
Generation X, Millennials,
and Generation Z, Homeland.
Those are the kids who
are being born now.
And so the Millennials are my
students, my college students
right now.
But what's important is not the
age at which these people were
born, these
generations were born.
What's important is
the age at which--
what was going on
in the world when
they were between 10 and 25.
Because those are known as
the formative years where
they become used to
whatever technology
has existed at the time.
So we look at that.
And we can see that these are
the bands of age at which each
of those generations are--
sorry, these are
the spans of years
at which each of
these generations
is between 10 and 25.
So we look at those.
And then we take
that and project--
we're going to project
that onto this graph, which
is a different graph.
This one shows
the range of years
in which certain kinds of
technology were dominant.
So we call this
technology generations.
So we can see that
1900 to the late '30s
was that the mechanical era.
Equipment was mechanical.
And from the late '30s to 1960
was electromechanical era.
I remember as a child, Hoover
vacuum cleaners and things
like that, things that were
partly electrical and partly
mechanical.
But I grew up mainly in
the analog electronic age.
And then there was the personal
computer and basic internet
age, the web search
and e-commerce age,
which hasn't ended yet.
Digital music,
social, and mobiles,
which haven't ended yet.
So the question is, how
do the human generations'
formative years compare
to these time bands?
And what we see is that each
of the human generations
kind of span a couple of
different technology eras.
So my parents, who were
in the silent generation,
grew up partly in
electromechanical and partly
in the analog electronic age.
You know, those stereos
that us old people
have in our living rooms now.
It's analog electronic.
And then personal
computer, Gen-X started out
with the personal computer
and basic internet age.
But was still in
their formative years
when the web search
and e-commerce started.
And a little bit when
digital music started.
And then we have the
millennials who grew up mostly
in the era of these
technologies, social and
mobile, digital music.
And Gen Z, of course,
who are being born now,
they're going to grow up
with all of this stuff.
OK, so let's look exactly
at what some of that means.
In the analog electronic world
that, let's say, I grew up
with, there is no notion of
navigating through a user
interface.
That is to say, a user
interface is all there
on the control panel.
And so there's the television.
There's the controls.
And maybe there
are some controls
on the back that
I hardly ever use.
And there's the phone.
And there's all the
controls for it.
There's the Zenith radio
and all the controls for it.
There's my auto dashboard.
And there's all the
controls for it.
I do not have to navigate
through the user interface.
So say you grew up with
that notion of the world.
And then suddenly you're
plopped into a world
in which there are multiple
applications on a screen.
And you have to figure
out which one you're in.
And go from one page
to the next page.
And then you look at your phone.
And now one moment
it looks like this.
And the next moment
it looks like that.
So you have to actually
get from one place
to another in the
user interface.
That's a foreign concept.
You did not grow up with that.
You had to learn that
after you were 25.
And that's not necessarily easy.
And here's a Tesla
instrument panel one minute.
And that's the same instrument
panel the next minute.
So you're having to learn
a whole new paradigm
for interacting with technology.
So that's why those technology
generations and the position
of your generation
while you were
doing your formative
years, why that matters.
OK, so there's all that.
That's a whole packet of reasons
why the age-friendly design
problem will not disappear.
But there is yet another
reason, which is that most of us
experience age-related changes.
And those are not going
to go away, either.
OK, so those
age-related changes are
going to happen to your
children and their children,
as well as to us.
And those changes occur
in vision, motor control,
speech and hearing, cognition,
attention, learning, memory,
and knowledge, and attitude.
And I would have to say
the bulk of the book talks
about these changes.
There's a chapter devoted to
each one of those bullets.
What are the changes?
And then what do you do to
design so that you don't--
those changes are not a barrier?
Now, before I go
into those changes--
because this talk and be
depressing up to this point.
When you look at that,
and you go, oh my gosh.
What do I have to
look forward to?
Nothing.
OK, so here's a slide
about some good things
about aging, which Kate
prompted me to put into here.
So that we wouldn't
all commit Hari Kari.
Oh, did I just turn
off the microphone?
Is it still on?
OK, good.
So cognitive psychologists
make a distinction
between crystallized
versus fluid intelligence.
Fluid intelligence
is-- and both of them
are measured, to a certain
extent, by intelligence tests.
Crystallized intelligence is
what you would call knowledge.
And of course, that
grows with age.
Fluid intelligence
is the ability
to solve novel
problems on the spot.
And that increases with
age until a certain age.
And then starts to decline.
And again, it's highly variable.
In some people it
doesn't decline.
And in others, it
declines steeply.
Greater vocabulary with age.
More real-world
experience to draw from.
Less tendency to worry.
Higher rates of
life satisfaction.
Senior discounts.
And as someone said, it's
better than the alternative.
OK, so because my
talk is supposedly
limited to about
40 minutes, I am
going to not cover all of
the age-related changes
that the book covers.
Not even close.
I'm just going to
sample a couple of them.
And if you're
interested, you can
read the book, which
apparently they're
going to be giving
away some copies of.
Or at least giving
them to groups,
I guess, to have as a resource.
So with vision,
for example, these
are the kinds of
things that can occur.
Don't necessarily occur.
But they can occur.
So decreased ability
to focus close,
or farsightedness is
another way of putting it.
Presbyopia is the
technical term.
Lower sensitivity to light,
heightened sensitivity
to glare, lens
yellowing, et cetera.
So here are some examples.
So if you're looking at
a screen of a cell phone,
and your vision is normal,
what's depicted on the left
is supposedly that.
So what that is is just a
standard screen of some app.
And then if you have
presbyopia or farsightedness,
and you've forgotten
your reading glasses,
which I apparently
have forgotten.
I normally carry them here.
You might not be able to
read what's on the screen
if the font is too small,
or the text is too light.
Then glare sensitivity is
just what it sounds like.
Because of a
lifetime of exposure
to scratches and things,
your cornea and your retina
might be scratched.
Not retina, but your cornea and
your lens might be scratched.
And therefore, you are
going to experience glare.
And that might
inhibit your ability
to read, or to see detail,
or to work at night.
I have friends who are
my age who will not
drive at night anymore, because
the lights on oncoming cars
are too glaring to them.
But consider this.
You're 28 years old.
And you go out to
the swimming pool.
And you pull out your phone.
And the sun's glaring down on
the screen that's not designed
for sun glaring down on it.
So glare sensitivity is not
restricted to older adults.
In some situations, it can be
applied to people of all ages.
Then we have lens
yellowing, which
is when your lens,
exposed ultraviolet light
over many years, becomes--
your lens and your
cornea become yellowed.
And therefore, any app
that uses blue versus
green as a information
carrying element
becomes hard to distinguish.
Or if as I've seen some
apps, some news apps,
put ads or pseudo news
with a yellow background.
Well, everything's
yellow on my screen.
So I can't see those.
And then reduced
light sensitivity.
The average 60-year-old needs
three times as much light
as a 20-year-old to be able to
perceive the same brightness.
And so things are
going to look darker.
What we often do when
Kate and I actually
give a workshop on
this topic is we
bring in a whole
bunch of sunglasses
and have people in
the room put them on.
And then it makes
the whole room dark.
And that's what some people
experience when they get older.
So some examples.
For example, tiny text.
So tiny text is a
rampant problem.
Everyone complains about it.
Everyone over 50 complains
about it pretty much.
And so the Social
Security Administration,
which you would think would
be aimed at older adults,
their web site--
let's just say the
method that they
provide for making the
font larger is not so easy.
Because what happens is
you go to their home page.
You say, hmm, I can't
read some of this.
Let me make the font bigger.
So you scroll down
to the bottom.
You see-- you look carefully,
if you can read any of this.
Eventually you find-- let's see.
Accessibility is
what I'm looking for.
And I'm not even seeing it here.
Oh, there it is.
Yes, right there.
OK.
By the way, visual search
among older adults slows down.
OK, so anyway.
We'll come back to that.
So you click on Accessibility,
if you can find it.
And then it takes you to
this accessibility page.
Which you then scroll down.
And it says, I
can't see very well.
As soon as you see that.
You see, I can't see very well.
If you can find it, then you
click on, Increase Text Size.
And you would expect that
to increase the text size.
But what does it do?
It tells you how to increase
the text size in your browser.
Which nobody is going to do.
They're going to hit back,
back, back, close the browser,
and say, you know what?
I didn't need to do that anyway.
Whereas at SeniorHealth, we give
it a thumbs up or a green check
mark.
Because basically they
have a little widget
on their home page.
Which you just click
the letter there,
and it makes the font
bigger or smaller.
Whatever you want.
In addition to straight visual
defects or deficits that
occur in some people
with age, there's
visual-cognitive deficits.
So as I mentioned,
older adults are
known to be slower on
visual search tasks.
And there's also difficulty
finding very small, subtle
screen elements.
So one small, subtle screen
element that many of us
are familiar with
is this little bar
at the bottom of our
Macintosh screen,
which has little black dots that
indicate that an app is running
or not.
But the people we talked
to in the senior centers
where Kate has done some
work can't see those dots.
They might as well not be there.
Now, one could argue
that on Macintosh it's
not that important to know
whether an application is
running or not.
But they try to provide
the information.
They're just not providing
it for a large segment
of the population.
And then we have situations like
this one at Road Scholar, which
is one of these travel agencies
that targets older adults.
So let's say you're
looking at a trip.
And you're thinking about--
it's too bad I didn't
bring my reading glasses.
Suppose you're wanting to--
you're looking down here.
And you're wanting to
travel on this trip.
And you say, OK, February 27,
2016, I don't like those dates.
Let me change the
dates of the trip.
So you change the dates.
OK, this is a good date.
I will like this trip.
But you may not notice that
the price, which is over here,
just went up by $300.
OK, now maybe Road
Scholar wants you to not
notice that the price
just went up by $300.
But anyway, this
is not good design,
because obviously there's sort
of a visual attention change
blindness problem
designed in here.
I mentioned that visual search
for older adults is slower.
So here's an example.
So if I put you on this
Amazon page, and I say,
tell me how many items are
in your shopping cart, that
is a visual task that
will-- a visual search
task in which people of all ages
will perform at approximately
the same speed.
Because everyone knows--
or at least people
who have been
using Amazon at all
know where their
shopping cart is.
Upper right.
So that won't vary by age.
But if I tell people
instead to tell
me what are some
of the benefits--
find some of the benefits
of Amazon Prime membership,
then what we get into
is a search task that
for the older people is slower.
And there are various
reasons for that, which
I won't go into right now.
Things are going on cognitively.
Then in terms of motor
control, the kinds
of things that can
occur as people age--
and again, don't
necessarily always occur,
but sometimes do-- are
reduced hand-eye coordination,
fine-motor control, strength,
reduced strength, slower
movements, and stiffness.
So one of the ways you have of
measuring that as a researcher
is noticing that a
Fitts' Law curve--
how many of you have
heard of Fitts' Law?
So Fitts' Law is the
law that sort of helps
you predict how long it
will take someone who's
pointer or finger is one place
to move to another target spot.
That curve flattens
out with age.
Meaning that the peak
velocity is lower.
The acceleration rate at the
beginning of the movement
is lower.
And so the overall time to reach
and hit the target is longer.
So what those kinds of
motor control changes cause
is difficulty grasping
and manipulating
small objects, difficulty
with continuous movements,
like click-drag, tap-drag,
tap-hold, pinch-spread,
double-tap gestures.
One of the things
that I am amused by--
or maybe not amused
is the better term--
on the Macintosh and
also on many iPhones,
the accessibility features are
turned on and off via gestures
that many older adults
cannot execute reliably.
So older adults have
difficulty often executing
coordinated gestures.
Also there's a decreased
consistency of movement.
Just because I can
click on that target
or do a pinch-spread
right now doesn't
mean I'll be able to do it
in a minute the same way.
One thing that's happening to
me with increasing frequency
is I'm trying to grab something
and drag it to a new place,
and losing it in the meantime.
And I don't know where
it went, if it falls
into a folder or something.
Greater risk of an
unintentional click or touch.
Accidental selection of objects.
So here's a video, again,
from the travel study,
of someone trying to book a trip
to Kenya using a website that
has menus that are pull-right.
So you pull them down.
And then you have
to pull to the right
in order to get the submenu.
You've all seen those
kind of menus, I'm sure.
So let's watch.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So like I went-- when I went
up here to get the country
first--
you know, I went up
here to go up here to--
it's bouncing around
the Kenya thing here.
OK, so I went in-- oops.
Down in Africa.
It's taken me like five times
to click on the country.
[END PLAYBACK]
JEFF JOHNSON: So
anyone had any trouble
with those kind of menus?
OK, so it's not
just older adults.
Then there are cognitive changes
like attention, learning,
and memory.
Reduced short-term memory,
less effective long-term memory
storage, less generalization
between situations.
People are more
easily overwhelmed.
So here's an example
of the latter.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- At this point,
I would call them.
This is so overwhelming.
- OK.
- I would call
them and say, help!
[END PLAYBACK]
JEFF JOHNSON: OK, now, this is--
I should say this person
travels all over the world,
sets up clinics, and
libraries, and schools,
is very well-educated
and very well-traveled.
Not at all senile.
But is totally overwhelmed
by the travel website
of the company that she almost
always uses to go traveling.
And so what does she do?
She looks at the site to
get out what trips exist.
And then she gets
on the telephone.
Cognitive.
So cognitive guidelines that
come out of this kind of thing
are to focus attention on
important information and calls
to action, which is not
what drugstore.com does.
OK, so drugstore.com is
aimed at people over 50.
But with all this
stuff changing--
I mean, we found that when
big images change on a page,
people think--
people who are especially
not in the generation that
know about navigation
and user interfaces
think that they've gone
to a different page.
It took me to a different page.
Why did it do that?
It didn't take you
to a different page.
It just changed that picture.
Oh, I thought I was
on a different page.
So the Android voice recorder
is the paradigmatic example
of simplicity.
Can't get much more
simple than that.
So that's one call to action
on the screen at a time.
And that's good.
In our book, that's good.
Literally, in our
book, that's good.
And then there's knowledge
differences like these.
So unfamiliar with digital
tech jargon and icons,
not knowing control gestures.
But people have-- older people
have greater domain knowledge.
That is, tests have shown
that older adults are actually
better at doing search
tasks when the search
tasks are ill-defined.
They're not as good as
younger people at doing
well-defined search tasks.
What is the capital of Brazil?
OK, that's a
well-defined search task.
But an ill-defined search
task is, find a vacation
that you would like.
That's ill-defined.
Older adults actually
have more domain knowledge
and can solve those
problems usually faster
than young adults.
So here's an example of
unfamiliar vocabulary.
"Check for update.
A new update is available.
In this version, you
will have the option
to select between Light
and Dark UI themes
from the Settings menu."
Well, my aunt would think that
that is unemployment insurance
or something.
UI is a technical term
that we use in the field.
It should not be in a user
interface of a mobile phone.
And one of my pet peeves
is what is the menu--
what is the symbol for a menu?
Well, over here in this app is--
and so this is
Android's voicemail app.
The menu is three dots.
In Google Translate,
it's the hamburger.
In Waze it's a dancing pig.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so let's-- can we agree
that it would be a good idea
to settle on one symbol
for what a menu is?
Rather than having
ones that not only--
see, what we're
doing is requiring
people who didn't grow
up with this stuff
to learn these things.
But to learn them in the context
of having inconsistencies
in what are the symbols.
That's not easy.
I use UPS as an example of
a well-designed website that
works for everybody.
So the last thing
I'll mention is
that our book has a chapter
on why and how to include
older adults in development.
And actually, we
also have a chapter
on case studies of other
organizations and companies
that have designed
for older adults
successfully by including
older adults in the development
process.
So there are a variety of
publications and methods
for making sure
that the people who
you're doing your
user research with
include some people over 50.
Here's an example of some
students at a college who
are developing lightweight
walkers that are actually
more portable, and easy to put
in a car, and things like that.
And are very
lightweight and stable.
And so they developed
some prototypes out
of tubing and things.
And then they tried them out
with actual older adults.
So that's one method, is
really using older adults
in your research.
Another method that
has been used is--
it's called empathic design.
But basically you put
a suit on a 25-year-old
that restricts their movement.
And you tell them,
design a car that you
can get in and out of easily.
Ford actually does this.
And many auto-- some auto
companies actually do that.
They put people in suits.
Or they put goggles on them
that restrict their vision.
Or they put things
on their heads
that restrict their hearing.
And they say, design
a system that you
can use with all
of the impairments
that this stuff we're
putting on you--
that will work despite that.
So that's another way to
inspire empathic design.
So we give this kind of advice.
Include older adults
in participatory design
and evaluation.
Be sensitive in communication
when you're doing it.
Avoid technical
jargon and ElderSpeak.
And optimize the sessions.
There's a lot you have to do
when you're using people who
are in their 70s
and 80s when you're
doing usability testing that's
not the same as you would
do with people who
were in their 20s,
including allowing extra
time and eating the cookies
that they offer you.
AUDIENCE: What's ElderSpeak?
JEFF JOHNSON: ElderSpeak is--
it's sort of like--
you've read about kid speak?
So mothers talk--
motherese is the word
for when you talk to a
two-year-old like, hello,
Billy.
Please come into the room now.
You know, and use this sort
of stressed language, which
actually linguists have said
helps people learn language.
But when you do that with
older adults-- and people
tend to do this with people
who are in their 80s.
Oh, here's grandma.
Grandma, how are you?
Grandma's going, I'm fine.
Why are you yelling at me?
So when you go to
a senior center,
and you're helping people
learn how to use iPads,
don't do that.
So the summary is these things.
There's a lot of--
a growing number of older
adults in the world.
The percentage of older
adults is increasing.
A person's technology
generation influences
which technologies they're
going to be comfortable with.
And here's the thing.
I always like to say
people now, who are young,
think, OK, so I'm always going
to know how to use this stuff.
But 25 years from now, we will
not have digital technology.
We'll have quantum technology.
And the paradigms
will be different.
And so people will
be saying, I just
don't get this
quantum technology.
But my kids-- maybe
they can fix all
my quantum equipment for me.
So get used to it.
The world changes.
And you're not going to
keep up with everything.
You will keep up
with certain things,
especially if it's
related to your job.
Usability issues can
exclude older people
from the benefits of today's
digital culture, which
are great for that
population, for older adults.
The benefits-- you know,
I am a firm believer
in the benefits of digital
technology for older adults.
And we just have to make sure
that they can benefit from it.
So with that, I will
say thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Are there questions?
LAURA: We can take
questions live in this room.
We also have a Dory, which,
Tim, I think you have pulled up,
right?
TIM: That's right.
Are there any questions
in here first?
If not, I'll just
read from the Dory.
OK, so I had a question.
JEFF JOHNSON: And maybe
Kate can pitch in on some
of these questions, too.
TIM: So for me, it seems that
a big challenge in this work
is helping people to accept the
fact that their abilities are
changing.
What have you seen
that's helpful for this,
to help people accept the fact
that maybe things aren't what
they used to be?
JEFF JOHNSON: Well,
let me first say
one thing that is not helpful.
There have been
attempts to develop
computers for older people.
They don't do well
in the market,
because people look at them
and go, I would never use that.
I'm not old.
You see, the thing
is-- actually the AARP
has done a survey
of their members
and found out that none
of their members are old.
Only the parents of
their members are old.
So you're never old.
Your parents are the
ones who are old.
However old you are.
So any piece of equipment that
marks you as an older adult
is not going to be popular.
So the question is
how can we do this
in a way that
doesn't sort of say,
this is the technology
for older adults.
And this is the technology
for everyone else.
So I don't know if I answered
the question, which was,
how do you get people to
recognize that these things are
happening?
I don't really have a general
answer to that question.
I guess what I can say is
that, from my own personal
experience, it was kind of
forced on me when I suddenly
realized--
I had cataract
surgery in one eye.
And then they gave me a
fake lens in the other eye.
And first I asked if I could
have one that did telephoto.
But they said they
couldn't do that.
But now I have to wear reading
glasses all the time, unless--
when I'm reading at distances
closer than a couple of feet.
And so I didn't have
any choice but to accept
the fact that these
changes are occurring.
When I was in college,
I did gymnastics.
If I tried those things
now, I would probably die.
So I'm not going to do them.
Kate, do you have any--
KATE FINN: Yeah, I don't think
it's an answered question.
I think that in our
culture, especially,
aging is, like we
said, not sexy.
And people don't embrace it.
And people don't want to
admit to it or own up to it.
And what Jeff said about
stigmatizing people
by giving them dumbed down
interfaces or applications
is definitely not the answer.
People don't want--
few people-- you know,
have you ever seen
a jitterbug phone?
I mean, it's simple,
but it's pretty
insulting to a lot of people.
Depending.
I mean, some people, it's OK.
So I think that trying to--
my answer is we need
a cultural shift.
We need to embrace aging and
not make it so ostracized.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah, I
mean, in some cultures,
it's actually cool
to be old, right?
In Japan, it is--
the elders are more respected.
And if you happen to be a
Maasai living in Tanzania
in the Serengeti, the elders
are looked greatly up to.
But not in our culture.
AUDIENCE: OK, many older
folks are on a fixed income.
So they can't afford to
replace their phones or laptops
every three years.
What problems does this pose?
KATE FINN: Can I talk?
I addressed a conference
on the digital divide
earlier this year.
And the cost of equipment,
and trying to install it,
and trying to get technology
support were enormous.
And so many people who
fall in the cracks there
abandon the technology if
it's too challenging for them.
And it's really
irresponsible for those of us
who are responsible
for such things
to shut them out like that,
to not make things easier
for them to use, and
set up, and maintain.
Or for the government to not
make broadband basically free
and make an economic
divide, too.
So it's a big divider for
older people and people
on fixed incomes.
JEFF JOHNSON: Not only
the cost, but also there's
a mindset, which is,
this royal typewriter
was passed down to
me from my father.
And his father passed it to him.
Why shouldn't I be able
to pass on my Macintosh
to my kids or grandkids?
We could design this thing so
that there's a little module
that I switched out.
And that was the CPU.
And I put in a new
one every three years,
rather than having to spend
$3,000 for a whole new machine.
Right?
The display doesn't change.
KATE FINN: Instead of built-in
obsolescence, have it be a--
JEFF JOHNSON: Right, right.
KATE FINN: We talk
about, especially--
JEFF JOHNSON: Or the phone.
KATE FINN: --with
older adults, people
get hand-me-ups instead
of hand-me-downs now.
They give their parents or their
grandparents their old phones.
JEFF JOHNSON: Right.
TIM: OK, let me
ask this, which is,
I think, a little bit related.
So Jeff, I was looking back
through some of your earlier
writings.
And I saw that you were
writing in the '90s
about the public interest in
having a national information
infrastructure.
How does net neutrality
affect our efforts
to build a more
accessible world?
JEFF JOHNSON: Well
my personal belief
is that net
neutrality would help.
But it's apparently been done
away with as of yesterday.
I grew up with the
notion of the internet
as an example of something that
we formerly in the telephone
era called common carriage.
So common carriage
was a term that
was actually created
when stagecoaches
were running letters around.
And basically the idea is
that Wells Fargo stagecoaches
should not put any priority
on Wells Fargo messages
over anybody else's messages.
I should be able to put any
letter on the Pony Express.
And it should be
able to get there
in exactly the same
amount of time for exactly
the same amount of money.
So common carriage was born.
And it was applied to railroads,
and to trucking, and then
to the telephone company,
and then to the internet.
And the word for common
carriage in the internet age
was net neutrality.
And now that is
being gotten rid of.
And so the question is,
how will that impact what?
TIM: Accessibility.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah, so companies
that can control everything
and are not regulated
can always go
for the low-hanging fruit in
their particular industry,
whatever it may be.
One of the things that's
happening in San Francisco
is that the cab companies,
which are highly regulated
and must give rides to
people who have disabilities
of various kinds,
feel like they're
being regulated while
Uber and Lyft don't
have those same restrictions
applied to them.
So the playing
field is not level.
But so what we see is drivers
in Uber, and Lyft, and things
like that who just do not
want to pick up people who are
mobility-impaired, for example.
TIM: OK, I think this
is our last question.
It's the last one on the
Dory, unless I see a wave.
Oh, yeah, OK.
Let's have this question
before we do that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you
for your talk today.
What are your thoughts on the
potential for voice interfaces
to serve the needs
of older adults?
And I will stipulate that
there are real issues
to solve around comprehension
and comprehensibility.
But let's say we're addressing
those as fast as we can.
More broadly, how might
voice interfaces help?
KATE FINN: I think it
shows a lot of promise
in not having to relearn things.
Especially if we're not
talking about somebody
having to learn a command
line interface that they just
speak, if it's a natural
language interface and very
generalized, broad topic.
I think-- something I
actually talked to Tim
about the first
time I met him was,
I don't understand why
you can't say to Siri,
change my contrast settings.
Why can't-- it's kind
of a meta interface.
Because why do I need to know--
why do I need to know what
password, or what protocol,
or something?
You just need to do this for me.
Or I should ask you
to do this for me.
And I think that
if you lay over--
I don't know if you
want to call it AI--
on top of voice interface,
or some huge amount
of smarts on top of a spoken
interface, that that--
even if it doesn't
level the playing field,
would make things an
awful, awful lot easier.
Having said that, there
is some difficulty
with automatic
speech recognition
for older voices that have
trembles, and inconsistent
volumes, and things.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah,
the frequency of speech
tends to go up as we age,
the auditory frequency.
And she was saying they're--
KATE FINN: If the algorithm-- if
the recognition can handle it,
that's great.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah, I mean, the
problem that Kate was referring
to, for example,
is that it's not
that Siri isn't smart enough, or
Google Now isn't smart enough.
It's that they don't have an
API into everything that they
need to have an API into.
I mean, I'm surprised often
at what these things can do.
For example, they can
actually control the--
they can access the calendar.
And they can set up appointments
and stuff like that.
They can make phone calls.
So they do have APIs into other
parts of the operating system.
But if they can't access
the accessibility controls,
then there's--
somebody forgot.
Somebody forgot to provide that.
KATE FINN: Can I have one
little remark about this?
OK, to me, it's a big deal.
As people age, they tend to
become more socially isolated.
And we all read about, oh, it's
so important not to be lonely,
because that leads
to depression.
And in some usability studies
where they're like, here,
have this little robot.
Or here, have this device.
What has been found
is that, if you
have a reasonably
intelligent-- quote unquote,
"intelligent" spoken interface,
whether it's a robot or not,
that it alleviates some
degree of loneliness.
And I'm not saying, to heck
with your friends and family.
I'm just going to talk to
the voice menu on the phone.
It's not that at all.
But people can be so socially
starved that that does--
it does give them some
emotional benefit.
And they can feel
like they've got--
you know, like you hear people
talking to Alexa and Siri.
But it's some semblance
of human contact
that they might
otherwise be missing.
And so people who don't--
some people don't want
to do online banking,
because they're afraid
they're going to get hacked.
But they want to go into a
bank, and see the bank teller,
and exchange some
words with somebody.
And in elderly people that are
homebound, and they've had--
there's some robots in--
social robots, I
would say, in Europe.
And people find it's
like a little friend.
So I think there's another
benefit to a spoken interface
that we don't realize for
the general population.
TIM: It's interesting.
You may have answered our
last question, which someone
else put on to this Dory.
That was, which
Google product do you
think has the
biggest opportunity
for serving older adults?
JEFF JOHNSON: Which Google what?
KATE FINN: Product.
TIM: Which Google product.
JEFF JOHNSON: Product.
TIM: So if you look at
Google's products, what
has the most opportunity to be
improved to help older adults?
KATE FINN: I'm a Mac user.
JEFF JOHNSON: Well--
KATE FINN: The cars.
JEFF JOHNSON: Sorry?
The cars, right.
The cars, the driverless
cars, is a good place.
Because so many people use
the Google search engine,
that also is a good
place to improve.
It's not that it's bad.
It's just that, the more--
the easier the search results
can be reviewed and dealt with,
the better it would
be for everyone,
including older adults.
KATE FINN: And the speech.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yes, and speech.
So yeah, Google Now, the cars,
and this general search engine.
TIM: OK, great.
Last call for questions.
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: One of your
quotes says something
about very thin typefaces.
And that seems to be kind
of a popular design trend
in some areas, or has been.
And also light contrast.
How--
JEFF JOHNSON: Gray on gray.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I see.
Like medium gray on white.
And it's really hard to
see in a lot of cases.
What can we do about some of
these design trends and try
and--
I don't know-- nip them
at the bud, if you will,
if their usability
characteristics are that bad?
KATE FINN: I think you
have to rant and rage.
We're mad as hell, and we're
not going to take it anymore.
I don't know.
JEFF JOHNSON: What I do--
KATE FINN: Because I hear--
since iOS 7 came out,
there was this whole
minimalist thing.
And again, I'm mostly
familiar with the Mac stuff.
And I've tutored so many older
adults at different places.
And they just can't see it.
They can't see the
lightweight font.
They can't see gray on a white
or another gray background.
And the other thing
is popular was
white font on a black
background, especially
if it's small-ish.
And when Jeff was talking
about the Social Security site,
you had to go
through seven screens
to increase-- because
most of the people
that we dealt with don't
know, oh, command-plus,
command-minus to increase--
they don't know about that.
So the contrast and the size of
things is impenetrable to them.
I don't know what the best
avenue for complaining about it
is.
But it's an issue.
JEFF JOHNSON: Well, the best--
I don't think the best avenue
is complaining about it.
The best avenue is
teaching people what--
teaching future designers
what design really is.
That is, most of the students
who come into my UX design
class at USF believe that the
class is going to be mostly
about graphic design.
And I quickly disabuse
them of that idea.
I tell them that it's-- no, it--
first of all, many of
them think that design
is about personal expression.
And I say, it's not
about you at all.
It's about them.
So we have to figure out who
they are, and what they want,
and what they need.
But the other thing is
that it's not even mostly
about graphic design.
It's about making sure that
people can complete their tasks
or achieve their goals.
And that's mostly not visual.
TIM: OK, thanks everyone for
coming and participating.
And especially Jeff and Kate.
Thanks for coming
to Google today.
[APPLAUSE]